de faire un bon soir bonsoir alors vint
pourquoi pas 30 comporte 15 x 35 comment
vous a commencé à fonctionner quand le
premier ministre a dit publiquement
20h25 ça vous donne est quand même un
cadre non comment ça a marché mais
écoutez il faut comprendre que y'a pas
d'articles scientifiques qui va vous
dire qu'avec les simples idéologique du
québec le chiffre à retenir si 24 23 au
26 mois cerveau dit le premier ministre
est plus dur c'est du stress l'analyse
que j'ai faite en fonction de ce qui se
passe comme épidémie actuelle au québec
de la non présence du var yannick on
mais qui vont potentiellement à venir et
où l'année dernière et avait aucun
rassemblement permis à la maison pour
noël non parce tu dirais ils disent
extrêmement riches allemands eon temps
jusqu'à be there c'est un chiffre qui
résonnèrent par rapport à l'augmentation
des contacts mais aussi pour permettre à
certaines familles de pouvoir se
rassembler samedi au cours de modèles
mathématiques claire par rapport à ça
mais je tiens vous devez aussi cependant
que j'ai dit qu'on peut aller jusqu'à 28
des non-verts chez des vaccinés on est
obligé d'aller jusqu'à 20,6 avec des
grains est importante parce que j'ai
quand même dit virus qui circule même
parmi des gens vaccinés on peut aller à
- moindrement que sur les escales vrai
on parlait de ses résultats donc vous
êtes ça n'a rien à voir car le premier
mené du québec dit la semaine dernière
j'aimerais que ça soit 20 à 25 parce
qu'on veut que les gens passent un bon
noël vous êtes vous avez fait
abstraction de ça mais vous avez quand
même au même résultat
écoutez il faut comprendre que les
chiffres c'est ce qu'on ne l'ait pas les
à 100 personnes actuellement leur compte
et qui sont aussi les rassemblements
privés sont une hausse importante
très honnêtement moi dans mon analyse on
aurait pu rester a dit ce qui aurait été
peut-être moins 70 pour des québécois
qui auront fait l'effort de se faire
vacciner on aurait pu aller à 30 ou 40
mais moi je trouve que 27 ans c'est un
bon chiffre pour permettre à m parce
qu'on sait qu'un gars qui vont à 25 30
pour permettre de le faire et l'autre
élément toxique a mentionné est très
important pour moi c'est que les gens
n'ont vacciné là moi je vous dire si je
peut prévenir 3 4 go de mortalité ou 10
15 codes de gens qui vont sur intensifs
je recommande de sélectionner dès
maintenant
dr arruda je vais vous montrer un
tableau aujourd'hui par rapport à il ya
un an à la même date à peu près le
nombre de cas vous allez voir apparaître
donc le nombre de cas l'an dernier 1567
1234 donc ça j'en avais plus l'an
dernier mais il y en a à peu près le
même nom beaucoup moins de décès cette
année
hospitalisation c'est là où ça n'a rien
à voir on est à 2 135 est ce que quand
on dit vivre avec la coved c'est ça
qu'on veut dire c'est que là il va avoir
un plateau et qu' il faut vivre avec ce
qu'il va rester de virus qui va ce
premier c'est une très bonne question
que vous avez effectivement il faut
comprendre actuellement on aupravant le
même nombre de contrats voire clicquot
par jour avec moins d'un texte système
de soins c'est ça qui est extraordinaire
et c'est ça quand même de vaccination
parce que même si la vaccination revient
pas tous les records en termes de
maladies elle va prévenir les
complications sévères vous avez tout à
fait raison dans ce contexte là et je
pense qu'on va devoir accepter une
circulation plus importante par contre
les nombreux teaneck seulement ils sont
exempts quant à peu près 650 milles au
québec ces gens là quand le virus va les
frapper parce que vos les frapper ils
vont se retrouver à l'hôpital est aux
soins intensifs et c'est cela on veut
protéger et c'est sûr qu'ils peuvent
devenir un impact système de soins en
plus steve r on va probablement voir la
grippe d'autres virus respiratoires qui
vont déjà surchargé le système de soins
mais vous avez raison
ignore espérons qu'avec le au micron ça
va être un virus très transmissible mais
qu'il n'aura pas d'impact sur la
virulence ou sur la morbidité en termes
hospitalière mais ok de deux choses
les non-vaccinés vont l'avoir mais les
non vaccinés sont quand même de moins en
moins nombreux au québec là notre taux
de vaccination est très bon docteur
arruda vous avez raison coffret dans
d'autres pays mais il reste quand même
service sis entre mille personnes ne
sont non vaccinés ce qu'ont les gens du
protect le virus ils volent et cherchez
plus vous voir les feras tu es en
combien de temps à quelle vitesse on ne
sait pas mais si c'est raté ces gens là
vont se retrouver en mieux s'est alliée
et cerveau c'est une surcharge pour le
système de soins mais surtout une
problématique pour leur santé parce que
je veux vous dire se retrouver à 50 cas
ni aux soins intensifs peut-être mourir
même c'est quelque chose qui est
évitable grâce au verset d'accord au
micro vous dites et doctor fate chine
aux états unis hier d'autres l'ont dit à
des premières études en afrique du sud
qui montrent que oui il se transmet
facilement mais il n'est pas si
dangereux alors ça c'est une très bonne
nouvelle en somme ça apaise pas mal tout
le monde tout est fait vous comprendrez
que partent on s'éclate prudent parce
que les données vont évoluer dans le
temps mais si je t'avais reliant est
transmissible mais qui n'a pas la
virulence et quillan pêle mêle pas des
civils était importante et que des gens
vaty selon une protection qui compte
qu'elles sont sévères c'est le meilleur
des scénarios
dr arruda merci beaucoup de nous avoir
parlé en direct à la prochaine merci que
souhaite une bonne continuation du ska
noël roy bien merci à voir